um so I imagine many of you will know
who David bediel is but I'm going to
introduce you thank you from these
bullet points you're welcome uh comedian
author screenwriter television presenter
1992 performed in the UK's first ever
Arena comedy show at Wembley star of the
Mary White House experience new number
dealing pieces fantasy football sorry
the energy is tailing off yeah
um but that's a structural problem with
me rather than your career he has
Creighton presented several claimed
documentaries he's written 10 successful
children's books as well as four
acclaimed adult novels his last book
Jews don't count was the Sunday Times
political and current affairs book of
the year in 2021 and last year it was
adapted into a documentary for channel
four the new book is the god desire Ben
quash is the professor of Christianity
in the Arts at King's College London a
frequent broadcaster on BBC Radio
particularly interested in how the Arts
can renew people's engagement with the
Bible and Christian tradition he is the
author of the books found theology
Abiding and was co-editor of the book
heresies and how to avoid them and he is
the director of the VCS the visual
commentary on scripture a curated
ongoing online exhibition that puts work
of art in dialogue
I'm Richard ayuardi I I used to be in
the I.T crowd
why am I sandwiched between such
Eminence well David asked me so I must
thank you David and all and almost thank
my wife Lydia
um because she was taught by Ben first
as an undergraduate and recently doing
Masters and she suggested when Ben when
David kindly asked me to do this that I
ought to
immediately ask someone far more
intelligent and distinguished than me to
make up for my shortcomings so
thank you both for being here and I can
only apologize in advance so the first
thing I'd like to ask David is
why did you write this book what it is
what is it roughly about okay well I
might read a bit from it to explain what
it's about uh why I wrote it is uh I
wrote a book as you mentioned called
Jews don't count which I was asked to
write by the times literary supplement
uh I wasn't specifically asked to write
that book I was asked to write an essay
book they had this idea which is quite a
good idea I think to try and revive a
literary tradition which is sort of all
well used to write books that were quite
short there was probably polemical that
had an element of pamphlet to them and
so he would take a particular thought
that he'd had on language and politics
whatever it might be and he would write
I I know he would write like a hundred
Pages or 80 pages about it and they
wanted to revive that tradition they
said you could write about whatever you
like so I wrote about how in my opinion
Jews are kind of downgraded in the
identity politics conversation and then
that book did all right and they asked
me to write another one and I think what
they really wanted was a sequel they
wanted me to write Jews still don't
count yeah
and I didn't really want to do that
because I thought well I'll do that when
my career is going worse and so I
thought what else what else am I sort of
deeply engaged with what else do I give
quite a lot of thought to and it was for
me it was atheism but my particular type
of atheism which in a way follows on
produce don't count because in Jews
don't count obviously I talk a bit about
I talk a lot about being Jewish but I
also talk about something very specific
in that there's a moment in that which
turned out to be what I thought would be
obvious but it's not uh I thought it'd
be the on the nursery slopes of that
conversation which is that anti-Semitism
is racism and the way I illustrate the
anti-Semitism is racism and not
religious intolerance is by saying I'm
an atheist but that would get me no free
passes out of Auschwitz and that turned
out to be something of a breakthrough
for a lot of people who hadn't
understood that about anti-Semitism and
then I thought well I could probably
follow on about what it means to be a
Jewish atheist and to do that I need to
outline find why I'm an atheist and the
book does that and perhaps I should Now
read a bit so good give a sense of it
um so this is quite early on in the book
actually to explain this bit I'll just
read out the two epigraphs at the start
which I chose very late on uh in the
book when I thought oh it should
probably have some epigraphs before the
Divine Kingdom can be established in
events it has to be established in the
mind in the human imagination Bishop
Bishop Richard Harris thought for the
day BBC Radio 4 4th of November 2022 and
we cherish the illusion that exalts us
more than a host of Base our truths by
Alexander Pushkin and then in the in
page five I say when you write a book
you spend a fair bit of time thinking
about the epigraph in truth it's
probably procrastination writing a book
is hard whereas decorating a book
choosing a cover blurbs epigrams is not
comparatively I chose two quotes which
you may have just read I like those two
they are I think opposite but the one I
really wanted to use was this a close
friend once said to me but don't you
want to believe in God I said yes
desperately that's why I know he doesn't
exist
it's the opening sentence of the belief
system a book by an atheist thinker
Virginia Brooke but Virginia Brook is a
character of my own devising who appears
in my own play God's Dice and using one
of my own quotes as an epigraph is just
to Naf I thought I might be able to get
away with it on the basis of this book
is about the non-existence of something
so perhaps it would be apt to begin with
a quote from a book that doesn't exist I
thought that might be meta and clever
enough to carry it through but in the
end it's just to Alan Partridge a move
nonetheless the quote does sit at the
center of this polemic most Arguments
for atheism are philosophical sometimes
they tie themselves in knots grappling
with the issue of how you can prove the
non-existence of something at heart they
are based on the idea that there is no
evidence for God's existence therefore
he doesn't exist
my argument on the other hand is in the
general sense psychological it requires
an admission which is which frankly most
atheists I've noticed are prepared to
make which is I love God the idea that
is of him for the purpose of this
polemic I'm going to stick with the
patriarchal traditional pronoun although
I believe a modern God would almost
definitely have a Twitter bio that ended
they stroke them who would not love a
superhero dad who chases off death
some non-believers reading this will
think speak for yourself it's common
amongst atheists in trashing religion
also to trash the rewards of religion or
to be more specific to disavow the
presence in themselves of what religion
is there to serve there is something a
little Matt show in atheism some
atheists Divine correctly that what
religion provides for human beings is
comfort and then in a way that can feel
a bit adolescent they feel impelled to
say essentially Comfort that's for
babies but humans a subset of which
includes all atheists are babies however
old and intellectual and cynical they
grow no matter how adult and controlled
we seem on the surface underneath we are
a hive of wailing impulsive immediate
need I'm happy to admit to my own
babyishness that might be because or
rather why I am a comedian much comedy
is just that stripping away the facade
of adulthood we are all winging
adulthood truly there is only one adult
in the world whose age in his soul lines
up with the age he in fact is and his
name is Michael Gove
whatever
I am flawed and shallow and scared and
often desperately in need of comfort
both psychological and physical I am
however someone with enough
self-awareness to perceive these as
urges rather than ideas my thinking self
in other words is distinct from my
urgent one
not all the time I often find myself
thinking
I must eat now or I will die even when
it's only 11 in the morning but I'm
conscious even as I think it that this
isn't a logical way to understand the
world or even the phenomenon of feeling
peckish I know even as I experience
desire that it is desire and that desire
provides no frame for reality the god
desire should not have to lead to The
God Delusion yet the desire is real for
me it is the very intensity of it which
alerts me to the fact of fantasy the
need to imagine that there is an exit
door somewhere through which to escape
constantly on oncoming death is one that
I can confidently predict exist within
the Deep recesses of most humans and the
pressure of that desire has always and
will always lead to Divine projection
people talk a lot about what it means to
be human about what separates us from
the animals some of that is lyrical love
and empathy and stuff I personally think
it can be pinned down to the fact that
we are the only animals who feel shame
in defecating but whether it make makes
us human or not we are the only animal
that from an early age is aware of the
inevitability of death so it is
impossible to look at the repetitive
creation of Legends across every culture
and throughout history which in one way
or another outsmart death and promising
mortality without concluding that God is
a projection of a very fundamental
desire in that within us for it not to
be so inevitable
so that's what it's about it's about how
much I feel the desire that I think in a
mass psychology way has led to the
creation of God as an idea in many
different forms and this desire is
served by many different types of God
and not just the traditional
judeo-christian God and also it's not
just death it's also about meaning about
storifying life about providing some
kind of order to life some kind of
Justice to life all those things are
served by God and I feel those things I
feel the need for those things as much
as anyone else and the feeling of that
need is what leads me to my atheism
okay good now I'm going to ask for Ben's
response
um to the book uh when you read it and
also to the question of desire and what
it means to desire god
um in terms of your understanding with
regards to uh David's book first of all
I want to say thank you to David for
writing and the um
the fact that most most bookshops don't
stock any books in theology these days
until except very specialized ones
um means that I Rejoice that a book
that's actually doing theology in lots
of in the sense that it's raising
big questions about
the nature of the world the kind of
world we live in and what it is to live
in it well honestly and
um and to address questions like love
and so on these are these are this is
the sort of terrain of theology
um and unfortunately what you normally
get in bookshops is a little small even
not even a whole bookshelf sometimes
with a few shelves that just called
religion and religion is not the same as
theology religion is the study of a set
of human practices over time
more of a sort of social science type of
activity and theology is about what
you're doing it's about these sorts of
profoundly engaging questions We Care
Orient the way we live
um so thank you for getting theology out
in this form
um as a theologian I'm really grateful
and I also think it's it's you call it a
polemic but it's actually a very sort of
generous and quite vulnerable but it's
not really a poem it's not a poem no and
I'm so I I really enjoyed that aspect of
it too and particularly the personal
bits
yeah okay I know it's in a book but I
should have revived I understand
um
so I I do I really want to also
celebrate the fact that it's about
something much more interesting than the
existence of God which as I use you say
in the book and and the bottle has said
elsewhere in a way it's often a very
boring and unproductive question yeah so
I hope we won't spend much time on that
tonight I think that does the question
of desire and the desire for God is
really interesting
um
and I suppose my first response in
reading it was to to wonder about so I I
was I found myself having to ask whether
I agreed with you on the on on the huge
importance you give to death as a sort
of definitive
it's partly doing the explanatory job of
of of accounting for why we have the
desire it's because of death that we
have this desire
um and also clearly in your own
biography figures very essentially in in
your relationship with the idea of God
and
um and I the reason it's a difficult
question to ask is because one can
easily be self-deluding about this but I
didn't find Death as I don't find Death
as much of an issue as I think you do
um and and in some ways I I
you know I have a sense that if I can
get to the end of my life and not have
done anything too terrible I'll feel a
certain relief about it so definitely in
a way sort of stands for drawing stumps
and you know quite apart from questions
of the afterlife you know I I hope I I
won't have really copped it out right
um and also I quite like anesthetics uh
when the few times I've been in hospital
I quite like that sense of brief
Oblivion when do you like it uh both
when you wake up when I wake up yeah
okay good point thank you okay
but here but on that um ingmar Bergman
um once had an operation and this isn't
a great story so far but he had an
operation and he's he spent his life
anguished by a judgmental God a rather
severe Lutheran father and he said the
relief of his having Consciousness and
then it's stopping was the most
thrilling thing that had happened to him
at that point just that judgment had
gone and that there was no one pointing
the finger and that it just stopped and
he felt that gave him a kind of
confidence yeah I mean again that's a
judgment or a a you know something he's
coming to from the point of view of
Consciousness you know he can only make
that sense like oh I love the secretary
just before he nodded off she just said
but but I said of course it's from the
point of view of Consciousness but it's
an experience of not of
non-consciousness and a comfortable
being comfortable with the prospect of
non-consciousness in the future as well
okay well I should perhaps explain
something so two things one is the uh
individual experience you're talking
about the book actually begins with or
just before the bit I read which is like
Begins by talking about um how my mum uh
when I was sort of six or seven years
old and I first understood that we die
and I first got the that as a
realization which obviously we all come
to I'd sort of tried to talk to her
about it because I was frightened and
she said don't worry it's like a long
sleep from which you never wake up now
some people may know this about me but
I'm an insomniac and I think that's when
that kicked in because uh I I like
sleeping I love sleeping sleeping's
great when I achieve it but I think my
love of sleeping is a lot to do with the
knowledge that I'm going to wake up and
by the way when I you know a few people
have said this to me that oh you know
I'm not frightened of death kind of in
the way that you seem to be in the book
and I I totally accept that so someone
said to me the other day that Joan
Bakewell had been talking about being 91
and sort of looking forward to death and
in on an individual basis this I can
obviously see that to be the case what
I'm talking about here is a mass
psychology the way that cultures in
general will create a legend to outsmart
death and to you know all sorts of other
things that it will do as well it will
explain or and find ways through all
sorts of other things that seem to the
culture like this is not how I want
things to be or and I don't understand
this and I don't like this encroaching
Darkness or this encroaching earthquake
or whatever else it might be so
basically it doesn't need to be an
individual sense in which I can
understand and as an individual yeah
Bergman or you uh might think like no I
quite like the idea of sort of
unconsciousness but I don't believe that
that negates the idea that as cultures
we have tried to find ways around there
are many so many stories are about
Resurrection yeah and why are they about
Resurrection why indeed at the basis of
Christian prayer you'll have to tell me
the exact paper is like it's what is it
it's something in the funeral service
about how death will be vanquished the
vanquishing of death is at the heart of
Many Many religious ideas and why should
that be yeah
well I suppose
um you as you say your book starts with
this image of your mother reassuring you
um well wrong failing to reassure you
about death and I suppose in one way I
suppose saying it's not going to be
painful or frightening in some way it's
going to be gentle so I guess it brings
up the question
um of finitude which we were talking
about earlier and to what extent is
um would you call it a fear in a culture
or your fear or your fear which you see
occurring more widely which is of One's
Own Consciousness ending of of life
being finite how much of that plays into
your desire for God as
something that stops your own finitude
now I think that that for me that's key
and it's I mean I I mentioned in the
book something that atheists say uh I
think I'd quote Bertrand Russell uh and
Dawkins have said the same thing uh
Burton Russell said quite famously that
he would scorn uh to the idea of
shivering at his own Oblivion yeah he's
scornful about the idea that you should
be frightened of Oblivion uh now there's
two things going on there number one is
again this atheist machismo uh it's like
you know oh you know all these fairy
tales that people need to make up in
order to comfort themselves from the
ideas of whatever they're frightened of
principally death but all sorts of
things they're frightened of I the great
atheist need have no need of this I
don't believe that I think that's a pose
that a lot of atheists take in order to
feel kind of grown up and proper and big
uh but there's uh somebody else going on
there which is I think Dawkins has said
a similar thing but not quite you're not
quite as lofty away as Russell all which
is that why should you be frightened of
death because you won't know you're dead
and that seems very logical but it's
deeply for me inhuman because you're
only saying that from the point of view
of life and from the point of view of
life I promise you life seems a lot
better it really does like I I
like you know some people in here might
think well I I find life's so difficult
or whatever that I find the idea of
nothingness sort of more attractive but
I think that's unlikely I think that one
of the things about the book is it's I
mean I was born in Ipswich so
well
I when my mum was talking to me I was
living in dollis Hill in 1970
three so I can tell you that as I say in
the book was a kind of death but I I
think the book is powered and I quote
John Updike quite a lot in the book
Jonathan who is my favorite writer and
who was a Christian and deeply believed
in God but I think what I share without
Dyke uh Updike had an almost hysterical
but beautifully written attachment to
life like he was so like he a late book
by Updike is called terrorist it's like
a lot of update books it's not that good
but what it's about it's about as a
suicide bomber and you might ask why is
John up like writing about a suicide
bomber I think it's because he got old
and he thought I need to write about
someone who is in love in the way that I
am with life with death I need to
somehow manage the idea of death and
create the love that I feel for Life
throughout death he calls life this
complex interval of Light which I think
is so beautiful and I think that
that's you know the book if it has a
sort of positive energy because it might
sound a bit deathy the way that we're
talking about it but the positive energy
is it is that it's a deep commitment and
love of whatever life may hold even
though life holds lots of things
it's still for me better than Oblivion
and I think that
exists deeply in all of us even if we
might buy into what I think is a
slightly religious thing of well there's
a sort of serenity infinitude
can I just come because I think that
that idea of an interval of light
um it is is fascinating it actually
reminds me of the venerable bead the
kind of a great early British Theologian
who I think tells the story of of a
sparrow flying into the whole feasting
Hall
through one window and out the other and
he says that's an image of life you know
this brief moment where from the cold
and the dark you'll you're briefly in
this place of Noise music set laughter
and light and then out again
um but but it seems to me that part of
the
um
the conditions for being able to
celebrate and enjoy that interval is
that it's finite so there's a there's a
curious way in which death is the
necessary bookend
to all the good things that one enjoys
and a healthy this is true for anyone
whether religious or not that kind of
healthy relationship to one's own Death
Becomes a condition for
a properly celebratory
way of living now yeah and without death
and the idea that somehow your life
could just stretch on and on it would
cease to be a joyous thing at all of
course yeah but what you're talking now
is a kind of like
you know nice he almost humanist logical
way of thinking about death the creation
of God comes from a much much deeper
psychological soup that has nothing to
do with well obviously and I agree with
you obviously life would start to become
exhausting and meaningless and it's
weird if you just live forever it
wouldn't it wouldn't work that doesn't
mean you don't want it yeah because
wants and desires come from a much more
complex unsayable not logical place then
worked out in your head like oh yeah
that wouldn't actually be very nice to
live forever of course it wouldn't yes
the only thing though is that well
you've written a book yeah which is
logical and worked out and and put in
those terms
um but about uh psychology so it's not
necessarily the case or from a
psychological sense of why I might
desire this so they're perhaps not in
opposition the idea of something that
has worked out and rational and desirous
yes I don't actually completely agree
with that there's a bit in the book
where I talk about uh how God is also
like it's not just about death I think
God is also and I use update this update
talks about how uh he also it's a bit
about sleep as well and he imagines
humanity is kind of the child in bed uh
being comforted by the sounds downstairs
comforted by knowing that your parents
are downstairs uh and he talks about how
that sort of creates that there must be
something Beyond there must be because
there must be people watching over us
and that mustness that imperative is his
reason for why there is a God and it's
my reason for why there isn't let me
just explain something else yes
ready oh yeah well it's fantastic um but
one of the things is that I also talk
about God is not just being a way of
outsmarting death but also a way of
providing this parent figure and again
it's not as simple as like it's just a
caring parent you know I don't want to
get all Freudian on it but the way that
we might if we were to unconsciously
project a parent figure that is always
there for us they would also be angry
they would also be hateful they would
also be difficult we would also having
to be constantly doing things for them
that might not match up to what we
wanted because what we are in the
unconscious is a soup of anxiety and
desire if I wasn't going to call it the
god anxiety and desire because that's a
title okay well that can be the
sequel okay of course well that may
sorry that may explain because one of
the things that really interests me as
well is that
there was a theologian a 20th century
German Theologian who then moved to
America called Paul tillich and yeah he
described no I haven't except in the
writings of John Updike okay okay and
until it described three different
things that over you know it's a very
broad brush sort of meta narrative that
probably one we ought to be suspicious
of but he describes three different
points in Christian history in the 2000
years where people look to God to sort
out three different anxieties
um and death was the first one
interestingly so lots of early Christian
art
is centered on the idea of conquest of
death to triumph over death
um and and the sorts of things that are
depicted in are often
moments of Victory and it's either the
devil or or some
some sort of visualization of death as a
monster or whatever being defeated yeah
and then in the time of the Reformation
it's sin
and and uh and so what God does is sort
out not So Much Death but but the
problem of sin because people are really
worried about that yeah and then He
suggests that the the modern
big modern anxiety is meaninglessness
and you as you've as you've said in
summarizing the book in a way you deal
with the first and the third and there's
a sort of interesting hole there in the
middle about the sin one you're probably
right about that and it's interesting
that I have to bring in Frank Skinner at
this point because uh I tell this story
um I I tell this story about how when I
first met Frank
um I didn't realize how devout and how
literal a Catholic Frank was and uh we
went on a long journey on a long car
Journey uh and he was explaining to me
something very specific which I think
I'm going to tell you uh because it's in
its mechanics it's the mechanics
interest me so Frank at the time left
his wife
um and he was living I think he'd
actually got divorced and he was living
with his girlfriend uh and uh he was
having sex with his girlfriend now that
in the Catholic church is adultery right
and he was explaining to me that what
this meant was was that he couldn't go
to confession because to get confession
you have to confess your sin and then
promise not to do it anymore at which
point you get Absolution and then you
can take communion right and he's
explaining this to me over about an hour
and a half because I don't really
understand it and at the end of it I get
out the car at Birmingham New Street
Station and I say to him sorry why are
you bothered about all this and he said
no you don't understand I think I will
burn in hell fire because of this and I
literally had never heard anyone say
that you know I don't live in 1605. I've
never heard anyone say that and and
really mean it and I was really kind of
impressed at some level I didn't think
oh thus he's an idiot I thought that's
incredibly impressive that he really
really feels that that makes him more
interesting I've only just met him I own
more interesting a person than I thought
but what it does mean in terms of what
you're saying and that's probably true
is because I come from I guess a Jewish
background and obviously the book is
quite talmudic at some level
Jews don't have much of a conception of
afterlife and the Judgment that is going
on for Jews for orthodox Jews and by the
way there are 613 mitzvot which are
things you're meant to be doing all the
time as a Jew as far as I can make out
it's a kind of OCD thing where you're
what you've got to kind of wrap
something around your head or turn off a
light or not eat this bit of pork or
whatever the it is and and what
that what those people where that comes
from the anxiety and primordial soup
that comes from is anxiety about
judgment in this life and that comes and
I should have said this in the book this
is all kind of interesting I wish I put
this into my book anyway second edition
that comes from being a persecuted
minority that comes from the sense that
people are going to do bad things to you
all the time and you can't really do
anything about it but maybe if you do
all these weird things all the time they
will shield you from it but what I don't
have I think is a sense which you've
sort of mentioned of the idea of
judgment in the life to come and so
maybe that is why I've missed that out
because I guess
yes if you are really frightened in a
genuine way of judgment in the Life to
Come Oblivion may seem preferable I
don't think it really makes much
difference to my sense that God is still
a creation of desire and anxiety it's
just another type of anxiety I suppose
the question part of the question is
whether that is as primordial a part of
all human experience as as the fear of
death is and
um or whether part of what you know
you've characterized as some of the
differences between Judaism and
Christianity might suggest that there
are more
sort of historically inflected
circumstances in which some kinds of
anxiety Dominate and I guess that's
tillic's point
um so it might not be as universal
you know there might be more sort of
more more variety in the historical
contexts and the and the cultural and
religious contexts in which people need
God for different things
so you know there may be a there may be
something that's less primordial in
other words maybe it's interesting to
talk about I guess desire and what I
guess what we mean by desire what you
mean by desire how I guess you've
alluded to the idea that it's perhaps
not entirely conscious yeah to what
degree do you choose what you desire as
Updike I think said I chose to believe
in God yes that he he made that
consciously and CSUS would say if your
rationality Gets In Your Way gets in the
way of your faith then don't have it as
it has to involve your rationality but
so I guess my question is
how do you know what you're Desiring is
it by seeing what your life is like and
go
oh I can back
sort of reverse engineer from what it
seems to be I'm projecting how can you
tell what your desires are I suppose
yeah
that's a really good question I think
because I think in the book I am retro
engineering I am looking at what I think
God does uh in terms of what what he
serves in the human psyche and I'm retro
engineering and saying okay well these
are things that I feel which is I am
friend of death I am frightened of
meaninglessness uh I sort of wish there
was a more universal justice and I also
beyond that and that's more
psychoanalytical have a sense that yeah
there's all these anxieties and unknown
things so desire as a if one is to be
Freudian about it desire would always be
something you might not be able to
completely name and identify so I am
assuming in writing about the God desire
that some of those desires might be at
the Forefront of your head and some that
will be almost unnamable and that is
partly why I think the imagination of
God isn't just a straightforward thing
and it certainly isn't just
straightforwardly a good nice thing
right I think
um because I think we're trying to play
out all sorts of things that might come
under the headline of Desire but I I
wouldn't be able to say you can name all
of them yeah and yes what was your
response to the question of desire
within the book and and is there a
specific kind of desire for God that is
different
from other desires
I think there is yeah well okay so the
the one of the classic statements about
desire is Central Augustine the the
fourth and early fifth century Bishop in
North Africa
um who who says in the in his
confessions our hearts are restless till
they find their rest in you is he's
talking to God most of the book is a lot
of extended address to God it's just a
desire he also says God make me celibate
but not yet yeah there's that great one
but yeah
continents you know he wants consonants
only when yeah the title is right yeah
um but the that that sense of the heart
being Restless until it Finds Its rest
is probably one of the most paradigmatic
theological statements of what desire
for God is it's the sort of ultimate red
it's connected with the idea of ultimate
rest and
um we it's quite proper from Augustine's
point of view to desire
anything that God has made so you know
the world is full of desirable things
and that's good
but the problem as Augustine sees it is
to desire them as though they are
they're going to give you that final
rest
um even even those you most dearly love
um
you know they won't ultimately abide and
you and so you know there's always going
to be a sense of loss and so I'm saying
the way he's dealing with some of the
same anxieties that you describe of
losing your parents and losing your best
friend
um and he go he describes these
experiences of bereavement in the book
um so for him the key thing about the
desire for God is that it's the God is
the only object
that doesn't let you down in the end and
the way to love things in the world is
to love them as as if you like
oh a part of your love for God as a way
of loving God rather than as if they
were God so I guess that would be that's
hiding behind Augustine back that would
be part of an answer that I feel
has some interest well you brought up
something which I think is important
which slightly takes us back to what
we're talking about earlier which is to
talk about being very frightened of
death can make you feel in a way very
narcissistic I sort of deal with this in
the book about how uh early on in my
life I read about the idea that it was
very narcissistic to be very frightened
of your own Extinction and then actually
again I know we've mentioned him a lot
of Updike in self-consciousness which I
think you've got there that's under
there this is um pigeon feathers okay
self-consciousness he talks about how uh
it's the opposite that what you want if
you want you're not to die is you want
to be part of the social being you don't
you want to stay in the party you want
to be with people and of course as I've
grown older one thing that's become
clear to me as well is that if you want
to talk about the front of your head and
desires that you know about other people
you love die never mind you and your own
Oblivion other people you deeply love
die and the real and actually early on
in the book when I'm talking about me as
a six-year-old I'm praying I'm praying
to Hashem which is the Jewish the Hebrew
word for God and I'm praying that I
should see my mum and dad and my best
friend Saul Rosenberg again after I die
because it is about being amongst people
amongst love and above about about the
immediacy of you know friends and
relatives and whatever so I think that's
important in terms of like understanding
what I'm talking about the Cod desire it
isn't just like my own Oblivion that I'm
talking about here well the end of
pigeon feathers could be written for you
and when he's describing at the end
holding these two pigeons and um
he he says in the in the book The
slipping sensation along his nerves that
seem to give the air hands he was robed
in this certainty that The God Who had
lavished such craft upon these worthless
Birds would not destroy his whole
creation by refusing to let David live
forever right well that that's
so just to be clear if people don't
don't know so that short story by John
Updike is about a a guy who has a crisis
of faith and then sees a pigeon feather
and is moved by the intricacy of the
pigeon feather to confirm his sense that
God must exist because why would so much
as you say so much incredible apparent
energy and thought and physically Beauty
and Beauty absolutely go into something
and that's where we get into an
interesting thing which is so in this
book I don't spend much time I talk
about it a bit but I sort of like spoke
about what I'm dismissing certain
arguments like I'm not going to bother
with that so I'm not going to bother to
get into arguments about what existed
before the Big Bang Yes or is there some
kind of designer to the or whatever
because I kind of think those things are
basically unknowable no and what seems
very interesting about the book
um is you talking about what you want
and your and what's so interesting about
it is
it's as much a question to you and and
what you feel your desires are and and
what could possibly answer it yeah and
and so I guess along that here's a
question which is which I guess speaks
to what Ben was saying which is does
this desire for God make us live better
um live more meaningfully live in a more
worthy way
um is that true and also I suppose it
seems to me and this may not be the case
you seem to suggest that well truth is a
higher value than any conception of this
God yeah
um
and I suppose why
would you not write a book called The
Truth desire as in why is the desire for
truth and why is truth important to you